so if you've ever watched a White House
Press briefing you know for a fact that
Kareem Jean-Pierre doesn't like you at
all
but don't feel bad because she despises
someone else more she really dislikes a
specific reporter from Africa his name
is Simon atiba he works with today news
he's had a lot of hostile encounters
with Korean Jean-Pierre for some reason
yesterday she freaked out on him and
stormed out of the press conference
ending in early we kept track of this
weird Psycho Drama going on here are
some clips from it
she's asked about the origin of coffee I
hear the question she's the best person
here's your question but we're not doing
this the way you want it this is a
disrespectful it is I'm done Simon I'm
done I'm Simon I'm done I'm done with
you right now so what's the difference
between President Trump not doing
anything when the capital was being
attacked and President Biden not doing
anything when protesters when the
Supreme Court Justices were under attack
to say that there is no difference
that is that is just unbelievably wrong
I'm moving on I'm moving on okay
we're trying to answer your question
go ahead I just tried you wouldn't let
me go ahead I just tried and you would
not let me sir so your colleague is
going to ask a question go ahead ask you
a question no I just I literally just
tried to answer your question you shut
me down so now your colleague is gonna
thanks everybody I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
respect for America
it's a good thing she's unarmed or Simon
and Tebow would be in deep trouble he's
his correspondent For Today News Africa
and obviously kind of a hero he joins us
tonight someone thank you so much for
for coming on wait she I can you can
feel it watching that tape she is mad at
you why do you think that is
yes first of all thank you Tucker for
having me on your show there's a reason
why uh your show is the most watched
show in news in the U.S because you
bring people like me he's been a
disaster a total
um uh catastrophe a real nightmare
covering the Biden white house right now
I'm the voice of Africa in the U.S but I
can confirm that the level of
discrimination against me and against
African journalists in the white house
it's outstanding it's disgraceful
you know it's been three months that we
don't have questions at the White House
even as President Biden is about to
receive 50 African Head of State in DC
for the U.S African Summit she didn't
even give us even a single question I've
been trying for the past three months
and you know it's shocking because she's
black she's an immigrant I'm black I'm
also an immigrant and she's
discriminating against me more than the
white people who the white lady was
there before and it's it's it it's
shocking she should be ashamed of
herself for doing that and and and it
it's heartbreaking
she's obviously a bigot you can see it
in her face she really really dislikes
you do you suppose it's because you
don't have the same views that someone
who looks like you should have in her
opinion
yes so it I believe that has to do maybe
with two or three things the first thing
I sound different I wasn't born here I
was born in Cameroon I speak French I
speak different languages I don't have
the American accent I tried I failed and
I've decided to stick with my accent so
I'm an immigrant and she doesn't like
that and I add tough question for
instance I will ask her how is it how is
it understandable that President Biden
is inviting 50 African head of state to
the us who we spend almost 50 million
dollars each and you it doesn't have
five minutes to spend with each of them
he won't have any one-on-one with any of
those African presidents who are coming
here in countries where money is already
a big problem why not have this uh this
meeting on Zoom for instance you know
and so I asked questions about kovid how
do you explain that one million people
if you have to go by the official
figures one million Americans were key
by kovid and we don't know where kovit
came you lied to us you told us the the
covet came from bad to human and then
now we understand that he probably came
from the lab and that's the most
consequential question and she won't
even allow Diana from you know Daily
Caller to ask that question and when I
interviewed and say that no you need to
allow her to ask the question you know
I'm being blacklisted and it's
unfortunate it's disgraceful
well you are always welcome on this show
and I suspect we will see you again so
I'm going to but thank you so much we're
on your side
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight